you weren't in that video you weren't
there but i feel like there's like
a there might be a misconception and
obviously not with steve but like that
you guys are like
heavily on the political side when it
comes to that [ __ ] because i know you
know
when it comes to anything you guys have
a fan base that are probably on both
sides of the [ __ ] fence you know what
i'm saying yeah
but i want to you you weren't there so
it was like that's something
like did you know that was going to
happen because that's a big i mean look
whether or not you [ __ ] with trump or
not
that's kind of crazy to be on air force
it looks like i didn't go
because of like the trump thing probably
but honestly it was it was the time the
guys went up to
um dubai to do fight island with the ufc
yeah
and uh i was flying into vegas to
quarantine to
go do that and i ended up
i was on a plane with one of our filmers
who
had coveted or like got positive for it
so just because i was on the same plane
as him i wasn't even sitting next to him
but
it was contact so i couldn't go and then
so i had
i had to drive from vegas all the way
down to
cali stay in an airbnb for two weeks and
then
it overlapped onto the trump thing so i
couldn't do that
and uh and that's kind of all what
spiraled this like i'm quarantining
anyway so i started just working on like
other [ __ ] other [ __ ] and started
finding like like
yeah a lot of work there and um but yeah
that was kind of what spiraled a lot of
things i think in that in that direction
but
yeah but when it comes to the trump
thing and all that [ __ ] like i said i i
literally don't give a [ __ ] about
politics like one bit like
i feel like yeah you and kyle are dudes
from canada who get free health care and
you know
yeah we're just like like just it's a
joke right i got an opportunity to [ __ ]
around with like some trump [ __ ] for a
title like you're going to do it like
that what